we had engagements we had the return of
the Blake down the thing is it's like
people say you know like Caitlyn made
mistakes our next Bachelor
Peter and we have our new bachelor
everybody so grateful right now just to
have this opportunity in front of me
this is your bachelor in paradise tail
off finale three-hour special recap grab
your glasses it's time for roses and
rose
hi you guys we have a different blanket
why because it's gold golden for our new
golden boy Peter Webber is the bachelor
yes the announcement was made at the end
of the bachelor in paradise towel on
Tuesday night on ABC so you know I
thought we could do something special
bring in a new blanket - golden blanket
to celebrate the new golden era of our
new golden boy but you know this blanket
is also see-through yeah so what does
that mean well that means I want to see
what you had to say about The Bachelor
choice let me know in the comments below
and I'm gonna take a drink before I talk
about it all look at the South Carolina
glass today you know we might need it we
were on a beach there was lots of birds
lots of animals all over the place
I'm a swan should have done let's scrap
the metaphors and just talk about it so
Peter Webber being our new bachelor look
obviously there was fandom for Mike
Johnson there was fandom for Derek Beth
there was previously bachelor fandom for
Tyler Cameron
but we know my boo boot up look I'm
gonna sit here and speculate they've
given us two great seasons back to back
Colton Underwood season Hannah Browns
season so much drama so much story so I
guess they thought that a season with
Mike Johnson as the lead wouldn't be on
that level
I am speculating that is my thought
so now the announcement of Pilate Pete's
Peter comes out and he says he is ready
for his parents love story thirty
some-odd years later now they're that
still in love with each other and I want
that for myself and I got a little
excited because Chris Harrison said
Peter is different from every other
bachelor
you're different than any other batch
we've ever had I'm like oh why Betty
says we've never had somebody who lives
about five minutes from the bachelor
mansion because he lives near the
mansion yeah no joke but what I can go
on is this Peter is cute Peter gave us
the window the window let's up the ante
Pete take it to a plane and I'm saying
come in and on this towel Peter Weber
promised us and I promise you one of the
best love stories ever you know this is
gonna be one of the most beautiful love
stories ever all right Peter you
promised and I'm expecting you to
deliver so pilot Pete promises and I of
course will be watching the new season
of The Bachelor let me know what you
guys think of our new batch in the
comments below
welcome to the unforgettable finale of
bachelor in paradise and now back to our
regularly scheduled programming the
bachelor in paradise tell all yes of
course we had to start with the
announcement of our new bachelor I mean
that's too huge to bury at the end but
you know there was other love and drama
in this three-hour tour did it need to
be three hours so some of this content
we're gonna fly right through because it
was a lot of the same please do drink
responsibly here at the end guys
speaking of the and I have a special
announcement at the end of this episode
of roses and Rosie so don't go anywhere
I feel like I am actually undeniably
myself let's go through our couples
right off the bat drink for every time
Demi and Christian were adorable change
my life and in love I saw in love with
you and it was amazing on the final
footage of paradise we saw Demi proposed
to Christian and then during the
teleport Christian proposed to Demi Oh
first double proposal engagement moment
ever on the show I walked on to this
beach and
clearly didn't know that I could deserve
somebody as great as you and now our
next happy couple drink every time
Hannah and Dylan were adorable
never
and in love I could never love anyone as
much as I and it was amazing
now Dylan proposed to Hannah and she did
take a weird pause drink during the
pause
but Dylan who has loved to Hanna since
he was a fertilized egg says you got
answer she's like
yes what did you guys think of Hannah's
paws I mean they were saying they're so
in love they want to spend forever
together they want to continue this I
think they're good they're fine they're
great and JC said they were the couple
he was the most confident in nailed it
and now things will take a turn yeah I
want to feel like a hundred percent
about us yeah I do too
drink every time Nicole and clay we're
not so amazing how am I gonna like ask
you to like up for your life and like
come live with me yeah they're not in a
good place but I want to be certain I
don't I don't want to be even 95 percent
sure we witnessed them talking about
heading into the fantasy suites and
Polly doesn't even want to go I think
like right now I need to kind of take
this night both of us to kind of kind of
think
[Music]
about everything don't even think about
tonight no honestly go I need my space
too
what did you say a clean eating time to
think about Nicole Nicole says that
she's blindsided by his uncertainty
I gotta admit I've been getting those
vibes from clay you know he haven't
seemed all in and then Nicole still
wants to fight for him my heart just
wants to say like fight for him because
I do love him so much she still wants to
show up on the beach why why why why why
why I'm laying down Nicole and that's
what you should have done just laid down
your awesome motel room ordered some
room service and some wine watched a
little Bravo and called it a day
do they have brothel in Mexico I don't
know I know what I want and that's
that's for us to take things slow and to
leave here together so they are on the
beach and she is fuming and he is
sweating I'll give them this their
breakup was fairly cinematic or at least
it tried to be we know Nicole was a
singer I did not know she was in the
theatre yes or no I mean she's
delivering lines about wanting a love so
deep into daily life that is so deep the
ocean would be jealous the ocean would
be jealous and she's telling great
I can't tell people that were together
no you don't love me back knowing that
you don't love me back what did you guys
think should a Nicole have given clay
that ultimatum but if he didn't tell her
he loved her in that moment they were
done well she did and they haven't
gotten back together so I guess that was
the way to go like to go I totally don't
move to Chicago okay
first we have the happy couples and we
have the sad couple now we have the
confused couple I have no clarity as to
where you are it's katieandchris hit or
miss everybody yeah I mean I won't even
dare you to drink every time Katie and
Chris went back and forth in this finale
on the beach he tells her he's the
luckiest man in the world I'm the
luckiest man in the world right now and
he's so happy so happy
he's crying and he proposes and then cut
to the tell-all portion and a lot has
changed bar for the course in Chris and
Katie what's going on baby your least
favorite sitcom if Nicole and clay are
soap opera Chris and Katie are a deeply
troubling docu-series about a topic that
you didn't even really care that much
about but then he learned so much about
it you got sucked in and I had just
depressed when he proposed Chris said he
wanted this to be the best moment of
their lives and it probably was because
it only got worse from there at the
tell-all Katie's in the hot seat and
she's confusing I saw up Chris she's
like I love him but things have been so
hard
we saw her ups and downs like every
couple I love them but I'm so tired I'm
exhausted and Katie's so are we perhaps
the best analogy for their confusion she
is so confused that she's not wearing
her engagement ring but says they're
still engaged we're so engaged what Oh
God
don't drink for every deep dark red flag
of a thing Katie says feel that I've
come to like a darkness I have never
been so insecure in a relationship it
doesn't always walk around Chris because
he comes out
Katy's in a dark place he's like a gray
area you're holding her hand cool you
could probably tell she doesn't have a
ring and drink every time Chris Harrison
I think trying to get Chris Bukowski to
be a little more emotional points out
that katie is not wearing her ring well
you could probably tell she doesn't have
a ring Chris what does that mean to you
that she's out here and struggling so
much that she died never ring on Eddie
do you want your ring back Chris have a
reaction III don't know and I don't know
what it what it means so I don't know
what happened during that hot seat Chris
said he still loved her and they walked
off but quick as a flash they're in a
new location so they've got a new
problem and it's always the problem we
don't understand and then they step off
a stage and I guess off a cliff Chris
and Katie are back to arguing backstage
and we still don't understand the
backstory or the next chapters of this
story he walked away are they broken up
are they not did she put the ring back
on is the ring off does Paulie have the
ring does Chris Harrison have the ring
does Neil Lane have the ring back is the
ring real what is this a facade are we
in the matrix did you take the red flag
pill or the blue pill now everybody come
on down for a quick fun round of other
crap that happened in the towel drink
for every fabulous moment first there
was security on set for Jordan and
Christian that the second guy looked
pretty bored and like he didn't think he
had any reason to be there although I
did enjoy Jordan saying that Christian
attempted to deliver an elbow to his
face
elbow attempted to be delivered at my
face and chest area I love an attempted
elbow delivery I acted in self-defense
you know the question was asked oh man
you probably get so many dm's like
what's that like
next up the Derek and JPJ fight Derek
said that things were resolved I've
already mended this fence but they
didn't seem to be and John Paul Jones
wouldn't apologize for what went down at
Chris and crystals wedding I think what
happened was unfortunate guess what he
did apologize in our interview after the
tell-all is available now a TT online
cop shameless plug also tej Vaughn is
here and our hair looks great
cheers to that speaking of aesthetics I
think Dean is wearing a bolo tie with a
C on it for Caleb they're still together
and even a man great how beautiful is
this and we brought back some paradise
alumni and found out that Carly and Evan
are having a baby boys on graduation and
that was revealed by wells jumping out
of a cave in a onesie
how hot was he Wells are you all right
we do have to talk about a few more
major plot points of the tell-all though
did you have any idea at that weekend a
stagecoach would be such a lightning rod
for controversy everybody buckle up for
the return of the Blake Dow yes the
Blake was in the hot seat and I had been
looking forward to this moment everyone
now was Blake's chance to redeem himself
to apologize to rise above after a
difficult to say the least season of
bachelor in paradise and things
happening off camera and off screen
when bleak released intimate text
messages between himself and his ex
Kaylin yeah I mean I kind of knew going
in that that was gonna I was gonna take
one yeah what did you guys think of how
Blake did has he grown has he matured
did you feel he redeemed himself tonight
ultimately Blake apologized I know and I
i upon her but it was after everyone
literally everyone told him to drink for
every person who said Blake apologized
she has apologized for overreacting so I
think you should apologize her as well
I'm sorry dude that's it
just end on a good note
and by the way Hannah told me her side
of what went down in Alabama between her
and Blake you can get that interview uh
but he did I tried to get my truth Alan
I am so sorry that you got attacked and
I am so sorry that you are feeling the
way you are I am I just don't think I
really got any resolution Blake still
defended himself on those text messages
do you see that that was a violation to
Kailyn releasing those text messages
like listen I knew that people were
gonna be mad at me but I felt like I had
to defend myself and Kailyn talked about
how there were other text messages but
she was choosing not to release them and
I still don't really understand why
Kailyn was so upset with Blake from the
second she arrived in paradise if they
had talked about how to enter paradise
together but I also don't think Blake
should have released those text messages
people say you know like Kaylin made
mistakes like him and you know both of
us made mistakes so I think we're gonna
have to treat this like the Blake Muta
triangle it's full of mystery it's dark
and scary and we don't want to go there
anymore but backstage Dean is adorably
supporting Kailyn and Kristina's
supporting Blake I don't know maybe they
should be together no they should not be
together okay but let's finish up but a
bit of a light comical note everybody
what am i referring to of course JP
Jason did you make a mistake in saying
goodbye so we find out the taster
regretted that Disney goodbye to JPJ I
flew out to Maryland
although I'm a bald girl and that she
headed to Maryland to get him and the
moment was so funny and weird and
wonderful wasn't it cuz she's there he's
like what's happening and then he says
will you be my girlfriend won't you be
my girl
oh my gosh and then he says look at my
girlfriend she's so hot
[Applause]
[Music]
we love you two together congratulations
all right everyone that has been the
bachelor in paradise tell-all finale
that was a lot of drinking so I hope
you're being responsible and I just want
to say that I appreciate the lots of
love that you guys have given us during
this season of roses and wrote to say it
has been a dream it has been a blessing
it is gonna treat an honor to discuss
this show with you as always let me know
what you think in the comments below and
of course we will be back for bachelor
though it doesn't premiere until January
6 but you guys I don't want to go
anywhere so I am here to tell you that I
am launching a podcast ooh yes I can't
wait to stay in touch with you guys on a
regular basis and if you don't follow me
on instagram please get me a little
follow because that's where i will give
all the updates on this upcoming podcast
and of course I'm on Entertainment
Tonight you can watch me there let's end
on a roses and a rose a note drink Rose
a for every rose okay
[Music]
nailed it
yeah I love you guys so much thank you
for watching hey it's time for roses and
rose may JC is here everybody oh we
couldn't have our final bachelor in
paradise episode out you and look how
good he looks he's got a new hair moment
he's got a sweater moment I'm just
saying JC for bachelor babe okay hey
guys that was what 17 weeks oh my god
what's that's right it was yeah
[Music]